[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play
markiplier the game someone actually
took the time to make a game about me
and there has been one game that I
played before about me but this is
actually full from scratch made on the
Unity engine really high quality bun
about me I'm so excited to play it I'm
so tickled that someone took the time so
let's just dig down deep go right in
there and start this game yeah oh ok so
anyway you'll find that this actually I
saw III I'm actually not gonna say
anything at all because this
I'm just so tickled shut up nurse it's
like my slogan there and there's
something in the wall
hmm I forgot why I put this paper up on
the wall oh well I've lost all my darn
warp alright I've lost all my darn warf
status' I'm pretty sure they're
scattered around here somewhere
I will go search for them I need a way
out of here I have been feeling a
strange presence behind that shelf for a
while now
mark with love sincerely love forever
and ever
mark as a tasty delicious steak press
cutie I thought that was gonna be
another quote from me but I guess there
hasn't been a quote of me eating steak
up on YouTube but either way okay
strange you know strange presence behind
this shelf c-can I do anything to it oh
wait I can click and drag it hang on
OOP I don't follow me okay thank you for
being totally Hollow wait can I see Oh
No I've broken the game already well it
wouldn't be my game unless I broke it
okay here we go well that seems ominous
and horrifying let's go into there I
want to see oh hello I gotta say I'm so
happy that someone took the time to make
a game for me I'm so tickled anyone that
makes anything for me I'm always so
happy to see it and this is just
absolutely amazing and I gotta find zero
of five warf
- is this is completely ridiculous
brother figure there's a I should really
stop putting these damn notes everywhere
people start thinking this is another
slender game anyways I should keep
moving
hearts and kisses xoxo mwah from mark
okay so anyway I got a worse - oh I get
it
I heard that I heard that boom little
tiny itty bitty poof okay anyway this is
I'm so happy I mean this is a extreme
narcissism right here by the way but I'm
so happy to be gay hi a little kid oh
you move okay
this is only a little bit disturbing hi
that's freaky okay anyway this is the
worst edge over here okay anymore oh oh
hi there that's it that's my sculpture
of wade in case you didn't know yeah
that you can tell I mean obviously you
could tell right away that was Wade of
course we made that during drunk
minecraft one of my favorite builds
we've ever done I think that's like part
three or four I'm not sure of the second
season that's my first profile icon ever
a picture from a while ago that's um hi
hi there little girl that's an awesome
photo show are uh fan art that someone
made one I was playing slender your
freaky why is there blood under the
chair why is there blood under the chair
I don't know okay and that was um that
was a fan art that someone did I I took
a picture of myself because there was
pig that was really cute now I'm going
to imitate him that I do okay okay
creepy alright thank you this is also
creepy I like it blah do you how what
idiot forgot to call the electrician
these lights are annoying oh wait it was
me gosh darn it I should keep moving
this place stinks like yes do I say that
I don't know I have no idea
I love forever I'll see you tonight mark
is absolutely ridiculous
yes really really really is this how
it's gonna be
oh look another war stack is I'm gonna
jump out of me if I'm gonna jump out of
me some oh man okay really this is a
wall good great I wouldn't have been
able to tell
oh nice music I love it yep
alright mmm the atmosphere in this game
is just astronomical I I feel so this is
lava oh okay well I really wouldn't have
known if you had but that did that I was
gonna make it you didn't let me I was
gonna but then you didn't let me ha I'm
gonna make it you just barely ooh you
touch my tralala
oh my ding ding dong I think I mean I
can I'm able to make the jump better
from up here I died dah Oh stupid good
thing this guy made a good respawn
mechanic cuz he knew that I would be
terribly stupid on this playthrough
I'm just embarrassing it's my own game I
can't uh I can't play it I'm that stupid
apparently I I shouldn't be allowed to
play games even games that were made for
me this is a III I'm having the time of
my lime having more fun playing this
game
then I have a lot of other games I'm
just absolutely ecstatic at this game
I'm actually oh oh there's the other
worst at okay I can't wait to make the
thumbnail for this game cuz I'm just so
excited I'm so excited okay anyway
enough of me being totally narcissistic
and talking about McJob
oh I thought I wasn't going to make that
one I thought for sure I was going to
follow god I didn't do that on purpose I
really didn't okay you can stop looking
at me like that
I'm not an idiot or I am an idiot stop
shut up don't make fun of me I'm an
idiot
HAP hey it's like a puzzle it's like one
of them hard platforming puzzles
there we go that's more like it okay now
we're oh this is oh the music changed
is it getting emotional now this this
game must represent the struggle of what
it is to be a markiplier true yes whoa
hey cool hi mark if you're playing this
I would just like to say thank you thank
you for all the amazing content you have
created I know this was a silly game but
it is my way of thanking you well thank
you so much game maker
I am absolutely honored that you took
the time to make a game for me
thanks for playing my game I hope you
enjoyed we all love you mark well thank
you guys so much this is actually really
works well because um I just found this
game after I made the video today and
I'm just I'm really honored you know you
guys have done an amazing job for
supporting me and just making me feel
like the most amazing youtuber in the
world because I have the most amazing
fans in the world so I hope you guys had
fun I think this is the end I don't
think there's any more so anyway thank
you all so much for watching thank you
game makers so much for making the game
for me you can find the game in the
description below as always thanks again
everybody and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh awesome
and